everyone's a critic before our episode
on music criticism we chose to focus on
YouTube music critic Anthony Fanta knows
the needle drop BAM
hey everyone Anthony Fantino here
the Internet's busiest music nerd one
because his scoring system makes it
crystal clear what he considers better
or worse music and two because one of
our producers is a huge fan and gets
really upset when he gives young fellow
scores I'm feeling strong for to Ally
five on this thing so we want to unlock
the code of how to get a good rating
from Anthony so that we can create our
own needle drop approved song nari and I
are gonna produce a track with the help
of Anthony Fasano
we're trying to find a track that you
can join us on cool but what do you feel
like the purpose of music critics is I
think it's more of a service of curation
and allowing the audience to know in
this very saturated field of music this
is stuff that I think is worth your time
how important do you feel it is for
critics to actually be musicians I don't
know if it's super essential because I
know there are a lot of super successful
critics whose opinions that I think over
the years have proven to be super valid
who haven't necessarily prided
themselves as being musicians I think
that there are certainly aspects of
music and music production that maybe as
a critic you should do your due
diligence to try to understand to at
least be able to comment on a given that
I'm reviewing records understanding and
knowing production or at least the
basics of it that's kind of essential
because that that is literally the
process of making the album as heavy
since 2009 he's released over 3,000
videos on the needle drop as well as on
his other channel since we called
fentanyl and he's developed a rating
scale that goes from the zero to ten
with qualifiers such as appealing a
light to decent sectioning a decent to
strong 8 it's not good he's only ever
given the 10 out of 10 rating to these
five albums jkkk cup
qapla twisting my hair today
[Music]
he did give attend to the album pink
flag by wire in a special classics
review but since then the video has been
taken down so we'll just leave it out
for now and for a common point we also
looked at the two albums to receive a
zero out of ten
[Music]
so how does a piece of music get a
perfect 10 out of 10 rating and avoid
the zero out of 10 Fantana was the first
to call his own criticism subjective
even though I try to explicitly tell
people over and over and over this is
just my opinion it's not it's not
doctrine just like please like you know
form your own opinion disagree with me
all you want I'm not hating on you for
disagreeing on me after doing this for a
decade
have you given any ratings to an album
that you would like to change in
retrospect nothing like super crazy I
once hated it I thought it was garbage
and now it's amazing so that's it
videos over right just do your best and
hope he likes your music well not
exactly
we did find seven key elements that all
of his 10 have a 10 album shared I'm
loving this record freaking loving this
record and it just happens to be
fantastically enjoyable and seven key
elements that has 0 out of 10 albums
lacked 9 I'm not interested in that our
first tip is to go big or go home
one aspect that will get you into
fantana's good graces is to make your
music epic in grand and rich so dense
lengthy color the volume the texture
it's all on high this whole new record
is an undertaking in length cuts grown
into a 30-story monster it's two hours
long all that's it don't think just
making your music longer and louder is
an automatic ticket to a higher score I
do love loud music it's a pretty have
dynamics though contra know because you
because loud is not significant if you
don't have soft our second tip is
probably the most obvious if you want a
perfect score don't be sloppy this album
is a pile of slop they're so weak
they're so badly performed terrible
singing terrible bars flat production
cultivate the skills in order to be
precise crisp and meticulous tons of
precision so crisp they sound so
fantastic they sounds so clear so
meticulously placed together
of course we don't have to say that
there isn't any artistry or enjoyment in
sloppy music not everyone has to be a
virtuoso but if you're putting out
sloppy and poorly executed music you
probably weren't going for that 10 out
of 10 perfect score anyway maybe the
most striking point uncovered in the
making of this video
was that Kid Cudi received a rare 0 out
of 10 rating but then two albums later
received a 10 out of 10 rating could the
low expectations from the first 0 out of
10 record have led to the perfect score
with kids see ghosts fentanyl does use a
lot of language that expresses his
appreciation of progress I was left
after this album wondering where could
kendrick go after this he has gone
through this artistic metamorphosis
since the album was released I think
they've done a great job of improving
upon that formula as well so sounds
completely unlike anything Kanye has
dropped so far this year really dropped
ever it feels so good as some cuffs and
by contrast his frustration with the
lack of progress it's like it's it's
gotten worse than ever progress is good
it's it's not always necessary I would
say the daughter's record is a bit of an
example of that because the thing is
like they had almost a 10 year hiatus
between those two records and certainly
I agree that the newest record is better
I wasn't really like oh man is this one
gonna live up to the last one you know
the last one I thought was pretty decent
the fourth thing you need to know about
10 out of 10 music is that Fantana likes
music to be just beautifully cohesive
seamless they move so fluidly it's it's
always consistent it's present it's on
point
if you want your listener to become
truly immersed into your entire piece
you have to try your very best to make
sure that your music has some kind of
common thread running through them it
was seen another thing that fans Handel
gives high ratings to is music that is
troubled torturing demented sound
sickening murder scenes insane emotional
and mental problems
unsettling disturbing does this taste
for dark music give us insight into
fantana's character specifically or
might indicates something about tenets
in music itself billboard recently
published a study saying that 73% of
independent musicians report symptoms of
mental illness so either we have to be
brave enough to make art with our inner
darkness or those of us with darkness
inside are statistically more likely to
create the kind of troubled music
critics like Fantana value I was looking
back at like some of the records that I
put in my top 10 and some of the records
I gave tens - I was like man why are all
these albums depressing and then
recently somebody made a meme where the
golden retriever said Anthony Fantan oh
and then the giant scary be said music
Anthony Fantana likes I mean I don't
personally buy into the notion which i
think is kind of overplayed in a lot of
music writing circles that like sad are
is the best it's all about sad art dude
that hat
that happy yard and also I'm sorry am i
swearing too much for PBS I don't know I
think there's some really great records
that I love and that I've supported over
the years that have you know some like
supremely bouncy bright colorful
qualities to them music critics love
listening to music so give them
something that they really have to
actively listen to for Fantana
it seems that 10 out of 10 music demands
you to be tied to your chair and your
islands are peeled back it demands
attention songs on here do require quite
a bit of attention what is it
you love beginner guitar anything see my
name is Lucy this is essential if you
want them to give you their highest
level of attention
you've got to infuse your music with
nuance detail and variety the record is
a fantastic nuanced and very detailed
character portrait in short don't make
background music I do agree with this
but I would attribute a lot of it - like
a reviewers bias because I'm listening
to the record in a way that your average
casual listener might not be no amount
of complexity is gonna save you if
you're not being genuine well it doesn't
feel like a genuine expression of love
be free with yourself be free with your
music throwing out this idea of freedom
be open this world is opening get
face-to-face with your listener pop
being just so in-your-face and above all
do it unapologetically this really
trashy unapologetic character that the
MCU ride depicts it's funny but while
making this video we came across an
amusing reddit conspiracy that Fantana
only gives positive reviews to artists
who love shirtless at some point it's a
ridiculous conspiracy but whether or not
showing critics your skin gets you
higher marks opening up and showing your
vulnerable side will be rewarded I agree
so no barriers just connect I do love a
feeling of a record that is a authentic
that feels kind of raw emotionally that
is um delivering some kind of intense
emotion to you you know it doesn't have
to be like anger it doesn't have to be
sadness it can be an intense sense of
happiness as well sometimes artists get
rubbed the wrong way when they get a
negative review we just want to point
out that from what we've seen Anthony
genuinely wants the music that he's
listening to to be good he's often
rooting for the artists I wish it didn't
hurt feelings I wish it didn't create
negativity I wish it didn't but I don't
know what to do I don't know what to do
if you put yourself out there in any way
you're a vlogger you're a reviewer
you're a musician you're this you're
that you're going to catch criticism
people are going to say negative things
about you I have had horrible things
said about me over the years that I've
been doing this in my view especially
since I do my best not to
make anything in my reviews on the level
of a personal attack I feel like in the
grander scheme of things you could get
worse stuff than it reviewed do you know
many or some artists that you reviewed
personally
I've met some and have had some
acquaintance ships with them but I try
not to get too close for professional
reasons or does it help that you don't
know them to be free to criticize as
harshly as I try to prevent myself from
going to that point where I know them in
such a way where it would be difficult
to critique their music in an open and
an honest way because ultimately at the
end of the day what my channel is for my
fans so even if you do get a bad review
it's likely that some critics just don't
like your kind of music so the best
thing to do is to get out there and find
an audience that does so I have a
question what if you provided us with
maybe one of your ideal groups I'm a
baseline wait yeah and then we can go
from there that could potentially work I
can work with a drum beat as well I
could send you the drums Anthony we can
go le Anthony exactly because then
you've laid down the rhythm section
essentially and then you can just do
whatever you want on top of that we
think it's just so interesting if we can
see you contributing to a track that
maybe the audience can then review that
amongst themselves but just to flip flip
the script a little bit we're trying to
make a 10 out of 10 right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you think of our song did you
love it
did you hate it what would you rate it
and if you liked our show today
subscribe to see more episodes where
Ellie and I travel across the country
[Music]